what are we looking at here well we
started this diagram talking about when
you know calculus you can just know so
much more about a function and how it is
behaving we think of it we sort of
personified these functions like
characters and they do things they're
they increase they decrease you know
they have points where they stop with
this stationery and all these other
pieces of language that we have
developed so at the moment this is what
we know we started with stationary
points okay where does the graph stop
where do you have a horizontal tangent
we explored the very closely related
idea of turning points to be honest the
very first time I drew this diagram is
bit simpler it was just to get at the
idea that when you're finding stationary
points often but not always you'll find
turning points okay a lot of people
confuse these two they think I'm looking
for turning points I'll just find
stationary points and I'm done but as
you can see by this part of the circle
over here there are many kinds of
stationary points that do not turn okay
the flip side of that of course is there
are places that functions will turn
where there isn't a stationary point
there's no horizontal change at any of
these points so these are weird they're
not common but they do exist okay do you
did you get it out of your eyes just
just okay that's it go ahead guess it's
fine okay now the last part of this
diagram is the weirdest and trickiest
which is why in fact I'm going to give a
second diagram along with this and it's
these points of inflection if you
haven't written the heading already you
can points of inflection as you can see
are still related to stationary points
that's why there's this overlap if you
want both a stationary point and a point
of inflection if you both have a
horizontal tangent gradient zero and
also a change in concavity then you get
this class of objects here the
horizontal point of inflection okay but
you don't have to right so I'm going to
all in one hit show you three instances
of points of inflection the comment
types that you will see a bit are not
stationary so here they are tada
now let's talk about these one at a time
the most common one you'll get in terms
of points of inflection will look
something like this in fact the example
we looked at this morning is something
like you know you got a cubic or aquatic
or something like that and in between
some stationary points there is a point
of inflection okay you've got a concave
down stationary point a concave up
stationary points so somewhere in
between there if it's a continuous
function then there was a change in
concavity okay so this is kind of your
stock standard it's the easiest thing to
encounter in fact if you look at that
one and all of these other ones these
all come from polynomials so very common
objects okay but you do have these other
weird kinds of varieties now I've picked
out this guy even though you don't know
how to differentiate that just yet we'll
cover that next year because once you do
know how to do the calculus of
trigonometric functions this is the most
common type where it kind of like but
doesn't it doesn't like do a full on
like turn around like that but there is
still a changing you have any what you
might have to do is actually something
like let's see okay if you zoom in right
what I often resort to is when when it's
not obvious like this example up here Oh
concave down concave up what might be
helpful is if you actually let's do it
like this if you cover with your hand
part of the graph and you think well
look at what's left it's not a full cup
right that's what makes it harder to see
but that is that is concave up you look
at the curvature okay if on the other
hand you cover the other side you can
see oh this is concave down it's how you
can visualize that's not a proof
obviously but it gives you an idea yes
there is a change in concavity here and
10x is a very important example now the
last one down here is a weird guy we did
actually look at it earlier it's the
cube root of x so there is a change in
concavity but it's unusual if you have a
look about three pink asterisks on my
diagram because this is X to the power
of 1/3 if you recall when we
differentiate it X to the power of 1/3
forget about the second derivative as
soon as you get to the first derivative
what do you get this is 1/3 X to the
- two on three so there's an X on the
denominator you try and put x equals
zero x equals zero into that you get no
derivative which makes sense because
it's a vertical tangent which has the
gradient right then you go to the next
step and you say okay well let's go d
squared Y on DX squared let's see here
minus two over 9x to the minus five on
three same problem as before you still
have an X term on the denominator so the
second derivative doesn't exist there
either
there is no concavity at that point but
I can play the same game whoops it isn't
flying pencil if you zoom in and you
think ok let's cover this side over here
concave up do you see it
let's go came up as opposed to over here
that's concave down okay so I want to
talk to a lot of paper when I was
constructing this and I think it's a
pretty comprehensive coverage of the
important points that you can find with
calculus but now that you've got this
idea in your head we need to drill down
a little further into these points of
inflection and we get it in a second
diagram before I promise you though this
one is relatively simple can you draw
for me please a pair of overlapping
circles and make them overlap quite a
lot like this
okay so you can see there's a very heavy
overlap here and that's very intentional
the two sides of this diagram are very
similar to the ones before points of
inflection is going to be on the left
and on the right you've got the second
derivative d squared Y DX squared you've
got to be equal to zero okay so you guys
know how this works when you've got a
Venn diagram what is the part in the
middle me it means you are
simultaneously a point of inflection and
also at that point the Secretariat --iv
equals zero okay so in here this is this
is the normal situation okay so 99%
perhaps of the points of inflection you
will ever encounter are going to be of
this kind their point of inflection and
you find that the second derivative is
equal to zero so here's one that
polynomial that cubic I gave you before
okay so at that point you're going to
find the second derivative is zero and
when you test on either side you get the
change in concavity right in this
instance what's the concavity on the
left it's going to be it's concave down
so it's negative inside and on the right
hand side it's concave up so it's
positive so you see the change no big
deal of course I could draw this upside
down and it would just go from positive
to negative instead of the other way
around so no big deal the lion's share
of all the points fiction you'll find it
like this that's because if you want to
change from negative to positive the
normal way you do that is to pass
through zero does that make sense
if you want to change sides you usually
pass through zero but we already have in
our examples that we've looked at places
where you don't have to have the second
derivative being zero to have this
change your cavity we drew one just now
I'll draw it for you again this is the
cube root of X right there is a point of
inflection there I've visualized it for
you I showed you you can test on either
side concave up concave down but this is
the example over here right what
happened to the second derivative
there isn't a second derivative at x
equals zero so if your question says
find me points of inflection okay you
can't use this but you're not guaranteed
of finding all the points of inflection
doesn't happen very frequently it's like
I said this is the normal situation but
it does happen so you have to know
they're not the same thing now lastly if
you have an exceptional memory because
we did look at a lot of things this
morning think back to period zero I gave
you an example where we did this we test
it we found a spot but then on closer
inspection we discovered actually it's
an impostor not a point of inflection or
does anyone remember what the curve was
it's X to the power of four it looks
like of this in fact every even power of
X x squared to the 4 to the 6 to the
eighth to the hundred will look
basically like this shape and as you
increase the powers of X in fact if you
later on if you want to go into des
monts and put in like X the power of a
million it looks like this okay so what
is this at that critical spot down the
bottom you find the secretary of to be
zero but it's quite clearly not a point
of inflection it's concave up on both
sides okay
so therefore the language that we use if
you get asked to find the point of
inflection what I would suggest you say
is points of inflection and you don't
have to capitalize it but I'm going to
catalyze it now to emphasize it to you
may exist it is a very common error for
students just find the secretary to be
equal to zero and then just assume it's
done and they don't do anything further
let's suppose we do find this okay and
we're like oh at some random value x
equals 1 ok that's our solution to this
okay
what have I concluded have I found a
point of inflection no I haven't what
must I do after this we talked about
this morning that big flow chart I need
a table values
now this table values is not to be
confused with determining the nature of
a stationary point you're trying to find
points of inflection related object but
different okay so that's why this table
of values doesn't have the first
derivative in it it has the second
derivative so just like usual you will
go there's one
and then you will check in the vicinity
I do want to remind you just like I said
before the vicinity depends entirely on
the function you're dealing with okay
maybe one unit one whole unit to the
left is fine tes zero it's all good test
two it's all good
but your function might not be like that
there might be weird things that happen
nearby and you have to test closer so
you will get you know zero you have to
put a number in here right you can't
just put plus or minus because often
you're expecting a point of inflection
so you actually have to have some kind
of value in here okay and now you've
established aha it goes from concave
which directions this concave up which
looks like that
no concavity and then concave down I've
established the change does that make
sense